I'd rather hire a bunch of kids at a
high school who have 1450 SATs and no
college degree than a bunch of kids with
a college degree who have been told that
they are owed $150,000 a year for finger
painting virtually nobody learns how to
do a job by going to school virtually
everybody learns how to do a job by
doing a job and doing it a lot like my
my number one piece of advice for people
want to get in my industry is do a bunch
of stuff for free you can't teach effort
if people want it they want it and if
they don't want it they don't want it
I'd much rather have the person who's
like going to do the grunt work who
wants it I'd rather have that person who
slightly less talented than the person
who's more talented we just had Papa
John on the podcast and he said hire for
attitude train for aptitude I think it
was I think that's right